teilweise herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einem neuen video auf meinem kann ist
jetzt ja erklärt spielt egal ich sitze
hier zusammen mit sandra und wir haben
uns jeder haben erzählt diesen tag sexy
welt von europa jetzt spiele ja erklärt
jeder von uns hat sich zehn stories
überlegt beziehungsweise irgendwelche
ereignisse die uns im leben passiert
sind und die werden jetzt im anderen
vorlesen und die andere person muss dann
erraten oder wird sie sagen ob die story
echt ist als ob dieser wirklich passiert
ist oder ob das noch frei erfunden ist
x-factor der ja ich hab mir schon mal
meine schwester mit einer lampe
geschlagen damit war der mittelstand
wird die 3000 liege oder mir sicher bist
du hast ein punkt ich meine erste story
sandra ich habe mal auf dem weg zur
schule in die hosen gekackt wenn er
wieder aufgewacht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich wurde schon mal von einem vogel
angepackt und habe daraufhin mit seiner
eigenen scheiße zurückgeworfen
ich war schon zweimal wegen durchfall im
krankenhaus 35 ist als bisher hat nun
vom scheiß ich habe mir mit ein polizist
der im dienst war eine zigarette geteilt
ich bin 25 pole dann der nase sieht auch
schnell falls so großen polnisch aus
alter nein bin ich auch eine hecke dem
video ist die welt war maxi die darwin
nein du machst du dir fasst aus geplatzt
alter mit pompons ich war früher mobbing
helfer und streitschlichter gelbe kappe
da gibt es bei
ich habe gewusst dass kissen dicker das
hier kommt am 9
lukas ist das genauso gut aus wie mein
arsch für den getrunken kaya so katrin
an seine chance
die spitze alter die schweinehalter aber
sie haben sagen wollte dieses kissen
kommt am 9 9
lukasz ob das mit limitiert auf 1000
stück und es kommen noch zwei police den
lukas ob also 99 aber ein komischer
punkte ich habe mich schon mal mit einem
affen geboxt
[Musik]
ich kann mir das richtig vorstellen
doch was du für streicher bei gott ich
habe mich mit dem auch geboxt
svetlana hoffmann hat mich ja wurzel
blockiert wie es auf mich weil ich am
wochenende freitag auf dem boden
die schaffen nicht weg gemacht mich hat
schon mal ein alpaka getreten und
bespuckt
ja die geistlichkeit 100% alter ja
stimmt ich habe in meiner abiturprüfung
gespickt ja nein was nein ich habe es
nicht geschafft
hände hoch an alle die kein abitur haben
ich habe bereits vier mal einen flug
verpasst ja ich habe mich schon mal mit
einem fremden mädchen geboxt überlegt
mal bin ich eine aggressive ja ich habe
schon mal einen schoko bonn mit
verpackung gegessen
[Musik]
wie geht das
na ja da habe ich auch nicht ich hatte
schon war ein low cost wohnung in köln
66 vielleicht geschlechtsverkehr
nein ich dachte alter ich bin noch nie
vom fünf meter turm gesprungen
nein bisher größte schiff 50 euro wetten
wer als nächstes 15 10 10 15
ich habe mich schon mal einen lehrer
verliebt ja auf der schule
ich bin schon mal nachts ist das hat mir
im ofterdinger du bist nach zu treiben
eingebrochen ja wir schauen wir mal eine
eigene kurze probiert ich wünsche zu
trauen
aber ich sag nein ja nein technisch
respekt ein
ich habe mich schon mal an zahnpasta
verschluckt und danach gekommen
nach dem feiern ich kann daraus szene
geputzten verschluckt und damit
kurzzeitig eine allerletzte frage an die
ich ich bekanntgeworden
du bist eine scheiß karotte ich
verabschiede mich jetzt eine schmucke
bitte cook donnerstag immer sofort das
ticket ab 18 uhr da könnte ich leben
[Musik]
die skizzen kommt beim 99
den job als mutter sandra die geister
[Musik]